[Music]  eight on your side this afternoon supply  chain issues brought on by the pandemic  may now be impacting your holiday  traditions even your holiday decorations  you may notice fewer things like trees  wreaths garland this year it's all  because of those rising shipping and  labor costs all those delays we've seen  in other industries and because prices  are higher for businesses that could  trickle down just to the average shopper  also keep in mind that some items may  never be restocked because of the price  if there's things that you want for the  holidays that you know that are on  people's holiday lists you need to get  it while you can  because  if we run out i don't know when or if  we'll be able to get more in  businesses nationwide are asking  customers to bring a little bit more  patience a little bit more understanding  when you're shopping this holiday season